you might have seen one of these before
and at home DNA test the boxes might
look small but they're making a big
impact on some people's lives kits like
these have exploded in popularity over
the past five years
most people take them because they want
to know more about their background like
what countries their ancestors were from
or if they're really related to George
Washington and for many the results are
what they expect but for others the
results can radically change their lives
a lot of people take these tests hoping
for something entertaining maybe they
heard they're Italian or German and they
think it would be fun to find out more
but often when they get the results back
they're surprised by what they find so
how can that happen meet Sally we made
her up to show how this can work Sally
took DNA tests with her family her mom
her dad her brother and her sister six
weeks later they went online to check
their results the company provided a
long list of genetic matches ranked in
order by the amount of DNA shared and
measured in a unit called centimorgans
often DNA testing companies will return
a list of your genetic matches to you
they usually rank your genetic matches
from the highest number of centimorgans
you share with someone down to the
fewest number of centimorgans so you're
going to expect to share the most
centimorgans with the people who are
closest to you parents and children show
around half of their DNA siblings share
a little bit less half siblings share
around a quarter you get the idea
so naturally Sally saw both of her
parents at the top of the list they each
shared around 3,400 centimorgan in
common with her next she saw her brother
who shared 2,700 centimorgan and then
her sister who she shared around 1,700
centimorgan this was the first red flag
for Sally
why do these numbers look so different
it turns out 1700 symptom organ isn't
enough for Sally's sister to be her full
sister but it is enough for them to be
half siblings they talked to their
mother and it turns out she had an
affair in our hypothetical example Sally
found out that her mother had an affair
but that's not the only thing that
people find out many people have been
able to identify their biological
relatives when they were adopted other
people have discovered that they were
conceived using sperm donations but that
wasn't the only surprise in store for
Sally and her family Sally's father Andy
checked out his DNA results too he
already knew about the affair so he
wasn't surprised that one of his
daughters wasn't a match but he did
notice several names high up on the list
that he didn't recognize when Andy was a
college student he made sperm donations
in order to earn extra money and he
assumed that his sperm donations would
always remain anonymous but now many
people who were donor conceived can find
their sperm donors via DNA testing this
person shared 3,400 centimorgan with
Andy and as it turned out was his
biological son so Sally has been through
a lot she's learned that her sister is
her half-sister and now she has another
half sibling on her dad's side sally was
reeling from the twists and turns in
their family DNA when the phone rings at
Sally's home it's the police they found
Sally's DNA in a database
many people take more than one test they
want to expand the number of relatives
they can potentially match with another
way to do this is to take the results
and put them on a website that has a
public database many consumers if not
most are taking these tests for purposes
of genealogy they're not expecting that
law enforcement might be interested in
using the results to track down possible
criminals but increasingly law
enforcement officials use the databases
as well working with genealogists to try
and solve crimes mainly cold cases and
missing persons here's how that works
police take DNA from a crime scene it
usually comes from the victim or
suspected criminal then police upload
the DNA into one of the big DNA
databases and look for genetic matches
between the crime scene DNA
and others who have tested when there is
a genetic match genealogists are able to
use the information in the databases to
build a rough family tree they're then
able to use publicly available
information such as obituaries or
wedding announcements which are often
available online to get more names they
might look at Facebook and other social
media postings again to find more
connections between people once
investigators and genealogists have
created a family tree
the investigators can narrow down the
leads and figure out from the family
tree who was born at the most likely
time that the suspect was born who was
living in the most likely place where
the crime was committed
or someone disappeared for Sally's
family the call from the police helped
solve a mystery
law enforcement used clues from their
family tree to find a missing person to
be clear Sally's experience with DNA is
not the typical one it's not every day
that someone discovers a family affair a
distant half-brother and helps solve a
crime but all of these things do happen
and they're happening more often as DNA
tests gained popularity the growing
popularity of DNA testing and the
increasing sizes of the databases have
really raised privacy concerns decades
ago people were promised anonymity when
they gave up their children for adoption
or when they participated in sperm
donation and now suddenly thanks to DNA
testing people are able to track down
the identities of these people there are
a number of people who say that they
don't want to do DNA testing because
they want to preserve their genetic
privacy but the fact is that even if you
choose not to do a DNA test a distant
cousin that you don't know and may have
never met is possibly making another
decision and that decision is going to
affect your privacy as well some of your
DNA may be used by people to unravel
family secrets or track down potential
criminals or all the other uses that
it's currently being used for even some
uses that we haven't anticipated yet